welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by frasier
macleod who is one of the founders of
nexus search nexus search specialized in
executive search across the automotive
and consumer goods industries
fraser started the business in 2020 with
three other business partners max johnny
and stanley who all met one another at
their previous company chapman black
where they had all successfully climbed
the ranks before the company went into
administration
nexus search are now at 16 people uh in
the company um but due to sort of
continued success over the last 18
months they have big plans to continue
to grow the business and take it even
further over the next few years fraser
welcome to the podme
thank you for having me
looking forward to it so where we always
like to start
is the million pound question so i would
love to know what comes up for you when
i ask you like in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant in today's market
um so i think obviously there is you
know the the typical characteristic of
being the hardest working in the room
you know and i think yeah everyone knows
that in recruitment you know you have to
put the effort in um it doesn't come to
you without putting them hours in
but for me what i've noticed recently
since working more in nexus search is
accountability and that self-awareness
i think
you have to be able to have the ability
to be able to
know at any what any one time where
you're at against your performance
and be able to then self reflect on that
and you know work out what do i need to
be doing now to make myself improve over
the course of the next day this
afternoon the next week that continuous
analysis of your performance is what i
think really helps the modern day
recruiter
i love that so like self-awareness
uh discipline
just yeah knowing what you need to
prioritize and focus on
yeah
yeah i just love that
what's that you just lost me yeah i just
lost you there
i'm sure it's fine
we'll carry on but if there's any major
issues we'll it'll be fine yeah um
cool we can we can edit that out so
okay great so what i guess just just to
frame this up for people then what i'm
really excited to go over with you is
we'll absolutely
focus on last two years you being a
business owner we're going to unpack
that journey but i think before that
what we're what we're going to talk
about and what i'm interested to find
out from you is one this chapman black
journey like how you went from yeah
where you was to uh by the time you left
obviously a.d i'm sure i'm sure a lot of
people would have wanted to get to that
position so i want to find out from you
what we did differently how you got
there and then also as we just said
before we started right i think
um yeah people definitely interested in
like okay well as an employer at chapman
black when the administration went
through like what what that
experience was actually like so if we'll
talk about that and then we'll we'll go
into yeah then that transition of the
different mindset of being a business
owner right and not just having to worry
about your number getting the best out
of your team
so let's just i guess just wind it back
a bit then
so talk to me about
how uh how did you how did you end up in
recruitment so i can see
you was in sales and then you got into
recruitment how did you get sold the
recruitment dream
yeah so uh my first ever job was
actually 19. i was an i.t consultant uh
coming out of school which when you
think about is the complete opposite of
my profile um
and then um yeah done just a sales role
and um to be honest i just fell into
recruitment probably like everyone else
i didn't really know too much about it
very naive to it um but you know i just
had an obsession about working in the
city you know putting a suit on you know
i was always going to be successful um
and yeah i spoke to rex where did that
come from
where that was that from what do you
have people in your family and was
inspired was you did you not have that
much so you was like i'm going i need to
make it like where that come from
yeah my parents are not successful um
you know in terms of you know finances
etc i've never had that but i think it
was just always throughout school i was
always that person that
always loved business you know always
was obsessed about you know on being an
entrepreneur trying to make something of
myself and i think it just drove me to
to looking for that job that could give
me that as soon as possible
is it a quite a common thing for people
growing up in essex to think right i'm
going to be in london one day around a
fancy suit is that a thing yeah i think
yeah i think it is quite common to be
fair and that's why most of the
recruitment industries fielded people
for
[Laughter]
because like if i think when i was
growing up i did i don't know like
sometimes you feel to go like obviously
i'm from east point like the south coast
yeah i don't know you don't feel like
london city suits as much but i just
feel like whenever i've interviewed
people from essex it's like yeah i knew
i wanted to go to london have a suit or
that i think it's interesting
yeah it definitely is a common trait
[Laughter]
so okay so didn't know didn't know much
about it um talk to me about talk to me
about i don't know the first like
year or so then because that's typically
like yeah sort of the most difficult
period like how how was that how would
you describe that journey for you that
first part yeah
yeah so obviously i said i fell into
recruitment um i remember on my kind of
first day when i was there all i was
doing was i was only 19 at the time and
all i was doing was just asking everyone
you know who's the best in here you know
who's the one who's making them yeah i
was just so obsessed about just trying
to work out who was the one that was was
doing the best you know that was always
my obsession and um
all the conversation just steered to um
a gentleman that has been on it before
which was ross fraser um and it was
consistently directed to ross um it
turned out that ross was actually going
to be my manager so i was uh i'm not the
tournament but obviously i was super
buzzing at the time
um but yeah and openly it was just quite
a natural
job for me i've always been good at i've
always been confident i've always been
good at speaking to people and you know
building relationships has never been
something that i've struggled with so
suddenly i found this job that you know
you could do really well in by
communicating and building relationships
so i thought i just like hit the jackpot
for me um what where did that where did
that
of
i'm like not not everyone would walk
into an office and go right who how can
i learn from the best like why did you
think to do that
because that isn't common
yeah i suppose like i did have a [ __ ] i
suppose people probably did meet me back
then would have seen that as a 19 year
old probably did have a slight arrogance
around me you know i just always yeah i
did have that little bit around me
which i've had to grow out of as i've
you know moved up my recruitment career
but um yeah i just was it was just for
me i've always wanted to be the best
everything i've done when i played rugby
when i was young you know i've always
pushed myself to try to make sure that
i'm the best that everything i can do
and i think when i walked into that job
that day it was you know i was so
excited i see all these people um all
these young people you know on the phone
selling and it was just for me it was
just um really eye-opening and i just
wanted to know how do i become the best
in this business and yeah from there you
know i just um ross was only was only a
young lad at the time and um my
obsession become being the youngest top
builder that's all i cared about when i
really that's all you had about yeah
yeah in that first year like um
i i i did hit the ground running i was
pretty successful in terms of you know
understanding the job getting my head
around it and the goal for me was just
how do i become the youngest top builder
in this business and that's all i was
kind of obsessed over for the next few
years
what did you find out from ross then so
if everyone's going you like ross is the
guy that you want to learn from blah
blah blah what did you what did you take
from him which you'd probably
probably still pass on now or like what
were the main things you remember that
you took from him
i think probably the biggest learning
was that um and it was it was him and
also the other top builders in the
office what i kind of
what i kind of took from them was they
didn't always have the best call times
in the office you know they weren't the
ones that were doing the most pools they
weren't the ones who were doing the
highest call times
what they were doing differently was
when they were on the phone and you
listened to them on the phone the
information that they took off that call
was so much more than anyone else in the
office you know they would have a
30-minute call in comparison to a
one-hour call and they would take so
much more information they would ask so
much better questions and
they would come off the call and you
know i'd ask so many questions of like
how was that call what did you get out
of that and
it was the information that that ross
and the other lads in the office saw the
women in the office that were doing well
the amount of information they got was
just so much more impressive than the
rest of the office
um
that's interesting so do you think that
was just the questions or
or like just that the way they were
going about making like getting better
opening people up building relationships
like i don't know why do you think i was
able to
get more information
i think they um like before they go they
went into any call they like
they understood what they were going
into that call for
you know they weren't take they were
you know that's one thing that i
probably did take from ross is that
every call he went into he always knew
what he was trying to get out of that
and he would focus so much on his
questioning and his positioning of the
call to get what he needed out of that
and he you know really just installed
that into me i would say that's pretty
much learning from ross yeah no i love
that we yeah the work the work starts
before the call right and i think
we did a um we did a session this
recently and that was one of the the
tips and i think because especially
right now when everyone's so busy those
are the types of things that you could
get complacent with but as you just said
if every single call you go into knowing
like what what you what you want to get
out of that the point of the call or
that you're just going to have a better
chance of
making the most out of that call
yeah yeah that's why
that's a great insight
yeah i say that to my consultants on a
daily basis is you know every single
call we need to understand we're trying
to get out of that call you know we
gotta work out what is this call what
information do i need from this call to
take me to the next call um and then
we've got to make sure that throughout
that call we've got to position
ourselves to get that information
yeah no i love that so how long did it
take you did you achieve the young top
builder award mate
yeah of course
how long did it take then talk to me
um i won i won top bill when i was 21 so
it took me about 18 months to two years
um yeah
so i won when i was 21 um was this were
you permanent contract or both i've only
been a pump pillar i've only been in
person um and i've done automotive
recruitment
yeah and what so what
and that was the top of the throttle
what your team the whole office
it's over like a six-month period so
they do over a six-month period um
you know
you've got to be the top villa um
i had a really hot you know the other
the other person in our team who was
also hired similar time to me callum
yeah you know it was like me and him
just always fighting for it he was same
age as me and we just kind of yeah
yeah it was actually really nice to be
fair like we just had a really healthy
competition we knew that we were
at the time i would say we were the two
up and coming consultants in the
business we would yeah ourselves to do
things differently and we just created a
really healthy competition um yeah and
they would love that for that time well
it was on a is in a six month window so
that you use so they would have the top
of for in the last six months rather
than like the whole year
yeah so you would have it over six
months and then um if you've ever won
that you got you got like you've got a
rolex basically
uh that's it
yeah the classic recruitment love that
that's decent though
so
21 two years in
rolex must've been buzzing yeah i was i
was passing that yeah
love that that was very i was very happy
that's really happening yeah so so what
what what numbers did you have to hit
them to get the top villa
remember roughly
i think
at that time it probably would have been
about
probably it was around between 200 to
250 i'd say so it would have had me on
track to be like uh
yeah yeah in six months that's what yeah
yeah so yeah it would have been around
that all right so a couple of things
that i want to unpack here right so
okay cool so the first first thing
people really interested to find out
okay fraser so you got you got there in
that period and obviously you obviously
stayed at chapman black for for a
lengthy period of time but like what
what did you maybe do like people want
to know okay so if i'm right now if i'm
billing
i don't know 150 grand in a year let's
say yeah um but i'm listening to this
and i'm learning from people like you
and you're doing double that i want to
know like what what what what is fraser
doing differently basically or what what
did you what do you feel like you really
doubled down on or did differently that
made you go from i don't know maybe
doing 100 grand in six months to 250
grand was there any key things that come
up for you that you feel like you got
really good at
to get those sorts of numbers
yeah so i think um
i think what i did was i always made
sure that i was surrounded by the best
people in the office that was just like
another one for me that's just um so you
intentionally made sure you was around
positive people you wanted to get
inspired
yeah you finding recruitment companies
there's always like a the little groups
of generally the people that do well at
recruitment and they're always in a
little group and they're not too
accepting of the ones that are not but
yeah i don't even think i could to try
and get myself in there just understood
what they were doing i think that was my
immediate the difference to me and other
people in the business that weren't that
were that same level as me you know yeah
in terms of recruitment uh in terms of
recruitment i think um
on my i suppose it was my mindset really
i think if i was to go back to anything
it'd be my mindset i was so driven um
i'm always setting goals i was always
thinking about what's next for me you
know constantly what's next as soon as i
won that top biller award for the six
months you know i didn't say to myself
great i'm gonna go and enjoy this rolex
on my wrist i said to myself yeah there
ain't many people in this business that
have back to back to it not many people
have went and won it again you know and
my from the day that i won that top bit
award i went straight back to my desk
and it was how do i go and win it again
now
and that was that was my mindset and
that was exactly what i did and um
okay i just tried to always go that
extra mile um with everything i did
basically in the office really yeah how
do you sell to like really high
standards what um
talk to me about how do you how did you
set goals i know this may sound really
basic right but i think this is also
things that people like to hear so when
you say you're really goal driven
everyone could say yeah i have targets
but like did you have a monthly target
and you broke it down on a weekly basis
because as you said one of your first
things at the beginning of this was like
being set like having that self-analysis
knowing we need to prioritize i'm
assuming that's something that you've
done in your career but how did you set
goals that helped you know what you need
to be prioritizing where you're at which
obviously helped you
yeah so obviously i set the big goal you
know which is what you want to get out
of yeah six months you know whether
that's to win top biller and then it was
always i would always then work it back
to kind of what the the money i would
need to build is to make that and then
you can break that down in exec search
it's a little bit different in the you
know your average placement is 40 to 50k
so realistically you only need to be
pulling you need to be doing five or six
placements over you know six months
you know so maybe a little bit more to
really be able to achieve that so
then it's just okay so what's the the
pros i'm very big on that operating
model and just trying to work out what
is that process that you have to be
doing on a weekly basis consistently you
know to get the absolute minimum out of
your day
and
that's what i used to try to do a lot
and i think that i was very systematic
in my approach i would look at doing the
same things every day without foul and i
would never leave the office without
doing them um i think that's how i then
been able to i was able to then build a
consistent um that building track record
yeah
yeah yeah okay talk to okay on that then
people people would want me to know okay
what is what was your day plan then what
did it what what how did that work if
you had like if you were to think then
when you when you got that top live for
the first time what did your day look
like walk us through it
oh um getting back some views now
sorry mate well right roughly obviously
yeah yeah and i think um
obviously
for me i was always i had like five or
six accounts or five or six clients that
were always my target clients so i
always knew any one time who
who do i see myself having a long-term
partnership with who am i already
through the door with who likes me who's
giving me a buy-in and yeah every single
day i would always be contacting at
least three or four people inside their
businesses it doesn't matter what you
know where they are i just want to
constantly be making sure that i'm
always making inroads into them five or
six key accounts that was always like my
first few hours of every day um
i would there would be a reason for
calling though
why why like if
you're doing that every day so what i
would i would just constantly jim nine
out of 10 times i've generally had a
relationship to somewhere in that
account i've maybe done a placement
there i've got some relationships so
i'll just be going into every single
account with just trying to have a
conversation with them around
um
you know i had one one account was my
biggest account it was in he was in
italy and italian automotive supplier
and um
you know i just i would constantly be
calling all people all over the business
and just talking to them about the
placements i've already done you know
who i am today what i'm looking to do in
their business these are the candidates
i've got my network and i just
constantly be trying to build a
relationship there to see if i can grow
them accounts
um love that
that's what i did i did that
successfully with that you know with my
my major account you'd always do that at
the beginning of the day or you'd always
do that every day
yeah whatever you then do
yeah i think with exec search you're
constantly
you're constantly doing in that 360
model in that every search you get kind
of different so there's not that
opportunity to recycle your short list
as much as other markets so you're
constantly having to spend time you know
doing new searches on linkedin trying to
generate new candidates that specify to
the retained search are working on at
that time
um
so i'd be spending a lot of time doing a
doing a lot of delivery um
i think at the early days of chapman
black they hadn't got that delivery and
sales consultant role
right they didn't have that process so
it was very like you're a 360 consultant
go and do your job you know win
candidates do delivery but in exec
search it's a different operating model
but they didn't have that at the time
um so i would do a lot of delivery and
then in the evenings and i'm just
constantly most of my evenings was
either again rebuilding my searches
rebuilding my
bd list or i was you know sending
speculative candidates out to the market
to then allow me to go into my next day
with some opportunity to be
yeah so what so
how would you describe executive search
how like why is
are you judging it on because i think
you spoke about this didn't me like what
yeah how do you so i mean what i took
what i would maybe take is that you
like are you a lot obviously your
average deal size was like 40 50 grand
that that's pretty
that's that's that's pretty big so would
you do more seniors like executive
search was that because it was more
senior was it always retained how would
you describe executive search
yeah so it's executive and leadership
search i know that obviously i think we
do do leadership placements and um which
is more the secret manager placements
we're not going to turn them down
how would i describe its differences i
think um for me what i've noticed
recently since being nexus search and
being back into it and doing it on a
daily basis it's just it's just slightly
it's very relationship driven you know
you're not going to get you're not going
to get given a retained search for a
vice president or you know
a director
if you don't have you don't you can't
build relationships and you can't really
position yourself as to why they should
choose you over one of the bigger
players on in the market um yeah
and okay
and then it's just a lot it is a lot of
connecting the dots really because it's
because there is no candidates that you
can really recycle you know you've got
to take one call to the other you're not
just constantly recycling you know a
profile across the market and just you
know knowing you're going to win a roll
off of that you have to concentrate a
new bd into new decision makers um
yeah that's probably how i would
describe it just in obviously still
recruitment but that's probably yeah
so what what i just wanna what i wanna
hear from you then so again just still
focus on this sort of early part of your
career
so
what i'd i'm really interested to know
is like one of the common sort of i
don't know if you've seen this now i
don't know if you saw this in your
when you was a manager at chapman black
or now and you're growing the business
but like when i've sort of interviewed
or spoken to recruiters who are really
early on in their journey one of the
biggest thing that holds them back is
just this feeling of
i don't want to say imposter syndrome
but like for example let me give you
content so if i was in your shoes maybe
at that early stage and i was doing
these senior placements i was calling
people that were triple my age way more
experience than me like i could maybe
really doubt myself with him [ __ ] out
who am i to be talking to this guy
around his leadership position vp all
that i don't know if you see this now so
like obviously you quite quickly you got
you were obviously making deals you're
building relationships but why like did
you not ever think like [ __ ] on this
like essex lad 20 year old just calling
these people in italy vice presidents
and that who the [ __ ] do you think i am
do you know what i mean did you not ever
have that did you have to deal with that
i still get it today to be fair you know
i still really so you didn't have you
ever lose that yeah i don't think you i
don't think you ever lose that there's
always that sense of you know i am only
in my 20s you know i'm not yeah with
some i've not got some crazy degree
behind me you know um
block you not let that block your
performance or hold you back
yeah i think um so i'll say it tomorrow
to to my consultants today is i think
like i say to them that if you can
if you can have a candidate call if you
can speak to a candidate you know if i
if i was item is if i put a vice
president candidate in front of you and
i asked you to qualify them as a
candidate you would have no issues with
it you would take the call you would
have a very good call you'd come away
with really good information you'd build
a really good credibility because you're
looking at them as a candidate there's
absolutely no difference if you approach
them as a decision-maker they're still
the exact same person all you have to do
is rather than asking them questions
around why they want a new job you've
just got to make yourself sound relevant
as to why you are in why they are
looking like what are you looking for in
your new hiring strategy and you just
have to be confident that you can offer
a solution to that
yeah yeah
okay yeah it's just interesting
yeah because because i know a lot of
people struggle with that so clearly a
few people would like you've had to help
people with that right especially if
you're dealing with like you said more
senior people you've got this big deal
values right
you know everyone's doing 40 50 grand
deals and as as i said like 21 year old
fraser he's got a rolex on his hand he's
might have a bit more confidence then
calling people but still it's like
who must they think i am
like yeah i mean it's interesting
yeah it's definitely it's definitely a
common theme i think in recruitment um
yeah i think you know that probably the
top builders are the ones that are able
to navigate that feeling well you know
the ones that can get past that
for me i was just one them people where
i didn't overthink things i don't
overthink the river process i don't look
at recruitment you know
and it's not rocket science recruitment
you know there's
if you go in if you go in it head first
and you just approach it every day
the right way you know it doesn't matter
who you're speaking to you're going to
get success out of it yeah so
so the next part i just wanted to unpack
then and then we'll sort of move this on
a bit is
because i'm always in because this has
come up a few times so you had that be i
know you said that you came back in and
was like right on a back to back right
but
did you lose motivation
did you lose any motivation because like
that that's what i find interesting
because a lot of people listen to this
i do feel like the phrase the phrase
might the phrase might change because
top bill i don't know it's just
corporate like
the phrase needs to change but
like if a lot of people listen to this
probably want to be the top performer
whatever you want to call it right
but a lot of people i've spoken to like
it's more easier to get that because
you've got the motivation someone else
has got it whatever then you get that
and it's like [ __ ] now i need to keep it
oh i need to maintain it did you find
your motivation dipped at all yeah yeah
like for me for me getting up going up
the ladder to become the best performer
in the business and you know seen as
that wasn't the hardest part you know
that for me was
always something i could achieve because
i just had to keep looking at people
above me working as hard as i get there
suddenly when you're there
and it's like i've got people coming
after you you've got phrases
the other 20 year old after years ah how
did you maintain it then
um
probably was a period where i didn't
therefore it was a period where
yeah there probably was a period where i
didn't um
and that probably opened it up probably
wasn't down to my mindset you know did i
let it go to my head a little bit yeah
maybe
um
yeah there probably was a weight you
know i i did have some good mentors
the md of chat black guitar that you
know there was a few times where she'd
have to pull me in a room and just give
me a bit of a wake-up call you know like
let's just get back into it and that's
all that's all it took for me was just
someone to say to me come on get back in
the game phrase and then i'd be back
yeah
um on it again yeah it was
the definite when i was at the top was
the hardest because you you just
where did you what did you have to like
like for people listening to right now
then so if you if i'm there what did you
have to tap into did you have to tap
into more of like
right okay so i'm not chasing me being
this anymore it's like more about what i
can i don't know what did you have to
you have to must have had to work out
something that really helped you go in
i think what i had to do was i had to
change my i had to understand when i by
the time i got to the top up when you
was in the business i was like you have
to work out what your new motivations
are your motivations change constantly
and i had to work out to myself what was
them because you know earning money
being the best performer i've achieved
them now that where where what is it
that really drives me what's getting me
up in the morning now and i think what i
did was i look i worked out that
actually
what was the really driving motivation
for me was
um
was you know half not allowing myself to
now foul you know and i had to get into
that i had to really understand that
that's my new motivation and then i had
to go and find the next
you know the next step for me and my
recruitment career off the back of that
kind of yeah yeah i got you i mean so it
was more about being consistent
like okay
yeah it was just like from like you know
that was what was most of amy's was to
stay at the top um i had to do things
you know continue speaking to the same
candidates candidates decision makers
making sure that i'd stay disciplined
you know discipline for me has always
been a big thing um yeah you know
there's areas that i have an element of
me which is which could be i could you
know go a bit i'll go a bit on the other
side you know i can i've got that and i
just need to constantly tell myself you
know be disciplined maintain your right
standards fraser
okay
talk to me about so before we before we
start talking about the end of the
chapman black journey like talk to me
about and i'm sure you've obviously
heard this before right but obviously
really challenging period also can be
fraser just worrying about his own
performance his own number to then being
responsible for yourself but also other
people yeah like what what were some of
the the biggest challenges that you had
to work through as a as you become a
leader practice manager and associate
director that you maybe had to learn the
hard way or go right phrase i need to
sort of maybe change my approach here
what were some of the difficulties when
you went into more of a leadership
building manager role
i think the number one thing is is you
know accepting that you're no longer
going to be the top performer
you know
yeah that's that's no it's no longer
about you it's not just about you yeah
literally yeah i know that sounds like
he's he's no that's come up before it's
coming
before i just have to accept that you
know that no longer is about you no
longer you know you have to take away
that that selfish approach that i think
you do need to become
you know a top performer you have to
believe that and you have to come into
the office with a new perspective now
and it's you know
my job
is to now turn people into top
performers so rather than keeping that
information in my head i need to get
that information i need to articulate
that to people and people need to start
understanding and learning from that
that for me was was my was the biggest
learning curve i feel like i was always
a natural leader people enjoy being
around me people do you know they
people do get inspired by my
communication how i act i thought i had
that presence in chat black but it was
for me it was that transition of
knowing that i'm not going to be the the
guy anymore that everyone looks up to
doing it oh yeah everyone looks from a
billion perspective
yeah i'll get him in what advice would
you give someone that's maybe going for
that transition at the moment that was
like a biller but wanted to get into
like a billing manager role what what
advice would you give them to like start
getting more out of their team become
better leaders
i i'd say that for me you know there's
there's nothing there's nothing more
that
there's nothing more that would
fulfill me than seeing your team and
seeing people
become superstars in a business and it
doesn't matter how much enjoyment you
might get from you know winning a rolex
from being a top biller
yeah you know that that will the
enjoyment you get out of that does not
even compare to seeing someone walk into
an office that has no clue what they're
walking into you know and you are taking
them on a journey to go and be really
successful and when you do see that
happen for me that is the best enjoyment
you can get within recruitment so i
would say
you know just
go for it you know let go of that
selfishness and see that you can get
much more enjoyment out of being a
manager
yeah
so
to so jan 2020 then
obviously before let's get into the
we'll get into the nexus journey now but
before we do then let's talk about what
was fraser's experience of this
administration as i was saying
um
as i'm saying obviously before i of when
i was preparing for this i did some
googling and i saw some like funny
tweets like yeah
people heard chapman black people
fighting in the office people are still
in tvs computers all of this like what
was it as an employee of that business
like did you know it was going to happen
what was the what was the vibe like
where was your mind at like because yeah
you built out a successful recruitment
career here seven years that's obviously
still going to be
tough to
yeah i guess like what was your
experience
yes i could just take i'll take you
through
yeah i'll take you through that week to
say um
which i know is uh the recruitment
world's been wanting to hear something
like this for a while that was big big
news
um so i actually found out a few days
before
um i found out a few days before um
and
yeah i basically i just i had a meeting
with one of the founders um we were very
close you know we built up a strong
relationship over the past years he had
a lot of respect for me um i think he
just wanted to give me a heads up
um
so i found out
i remember i was in the it was in a
coffee shop underneath my flat at the
time um on a saturday
and um i just you know it was just a
complete shock for me i didn't see it
coming you know i'll run one of our most
successful divisions we were turning
over like three million just my division
i just yeah i don't see
just to make it really simple for people
like what what was that what act what
actually happened with they've run out
they're like no they had no longer money
to like just explain like what actually
yeah
you know openly we've never really been
told uh okay so
yeah we've never really been told
exactly what happened um of course they
run out of money you know they didn't
have enough money to to keep the
business going um
okay but i don't know exactly what
happened i think it's um i think it
probably was just a combination of the
business had three or four bad months um
where we probably were you know losing
quite a lot of money the business had a
lot of overheads at the time probably
you know
um swallowed up a lot of the cash that
was sitting in the bank and then you
know by the time they got through to the
new year i think it probably was just
they probably got advised that this is
just not going to you're not going to
get out of this
um yeah so they went into administration
yeah um but when i found out that day it
was a bit of a shock i remember going
back up to my flat i was in the lift and
i was just like so shocked going on yeah
but it wasn't even my girlfriend at the
time obviously worked at town black and
uh i remember going up in the lift and
i'm thinking that obviously she's got
until i've got to tell my girlfriend
she's unemployed um
and like you know so it wasn't even i
couldn't even really accept it as just
myself i've just got i've gotta tell my
girlfriend now i just hired my best mate
who i knew really needed a job i've now
got a call here
he's unemployed it was just a lot of
emotions and i remember going into the
flat i remember
um telling my girlfriend and uh you're
not opening i got really upset actually
for about a few hours i was really upset
like i
um it come over me a little bit i was
and i'm not really an emotional person
and i i was and i think it was just a
sense of
it was a sense of that i did i felt that
i was a part of that that let people
down you know i was one of the associate
directors um i had a big presence in
that office um you know a lot of people
looked up to me and i felt that you know
as much as it had nothing to do with me
a part of me was just a responsibility
yeah yeah
yeah you know if a business goes into
administration and you're one of the
associate directors then you know you've
got to be accountable for that to an
extent and it was just a little bit like
i had let down a lot of my friends in
that office people in that office
weren't weren't my colleagues they were
close friends to me and it was just a
real it was a real sad moment
to think yeah
you know and to think that all of them
years i i had worked in that business
the blood sweat is going to be
completely over
yeah for it to go out like that was just
a bit was a bit sad um but yeah then i
remember a few days later
and obviously he went into the office
when is the office what was the vibe was
people was people were like fighting or
what was fired
yeah yeah well i think what yeah i think
what happened everyone basically they
was meant to go on a ski trip there was
going to be a ski incentive the day
before and everyone was getting ready to
go to the ski incentive and like no none
of the founders were obviously in the
office they were doing what they needed
to do i was the only real person in the
office that knew at the time so i i saw
my mates getting ready to go to a ski
holiday i was like i can't let that
happen so i've had to run i've had to
basically pull him in a meeting and i
just took it upon myself i didn't ask
anybody i just pulled him in the meat
and i said look you're not going on this
incentive you know i'm not going to tell
you why
you know but you'll find that in the
next day
and i remember like everyone was like
really like everyone's just shouting at
me i was like what yeah um and then yeah
next day we just went into the office
and it was um
basically
yeah i think everyone by then knew the
situation um
and yeah the founder obviously let
everyone know that the situation um you
know he was very genuine about it um you
could tell that you know for him
personally it was an extremely you know
he was very sad he didn't want that to
be a situation um and yeah the office
just kind of went um
it just went crazy to be fair i think a
lot of people
yeah so no one got paid you know so
we went into administration on the 20th
of january
not the last time we had been paid it
was before christmas so you got a lot of
people
so a lot of people were waiting for
their january payday which is an
important paycheck i'd say out of the
year yeah
long period
yeah probably the most important
paycheck to be fair and um you know
everyone got told they weren't getting
that basically all right so that's why
okay so that's why there's also people
saying people are robbing staff and like
all that because they owed money
yeah obviously yeah no one was getting
their commission no one was getting paid
so i think it all just kind of broke
loose in the office um
not liking us not you know not i think
twitter was just a bit just typical yeah
no yeah of course
no but obviously yeah yeah yeah that
makes sense
yeah oh thanks for sharing that mate
yeah yeah so then it's nice
it's sort of gone i was just going to
say but it's nice to see that that
business was filled with some really
good recruiters because
a lot of people a lot of people have
left now and you know have gone on to be
directors and and um designed their own
businesses so you know chat and had a
lot of good recruiters in that business
it's maybe it was a blessing um yeah
people to go and push their careers on
now yeah so so you guys then obviously
started nexus search like was that was
that already in the pipeline then it was
already yeah it was in the pipeline we
had agreed to do that in november um so
in november we had decided to already
set up we was planning to set up in
august
of um 2021 that was our target that gave
us nine months to make sure that we had
enough capital um because we said we
invested our own money um yeah
we wanted to make sure we had enough
capital um i had a longer notice period
um so we was already in the plan that we
already had a name for our business we
had all that already set up so um this
obviously happening was just like a
kickstart for us um it was probably so i
guess not that we need it
the benefit is what i'm assuming yeah
obviously you could get started right
away no notice periods obviously
unfortunate thing is you haven't got
that january paycheck we would have gone
into the
report but you'll see i'm assuming you
didn't have any covenants
to like
you just have gone
yeah exactly so we didn't have any
covenants which was a massive help for
us um i think probably anyone yourself
for business would say that would be a
lovely thing to have
yeah for sure obviously we capitalized
on that um it was a good it was a great
opportunity for us now we now look back
i think that it was so perfect and
considering that kovid was two months
away
um
[Music]
it's more i look back here i think would
we would we have actually set up because
if we had waited till august yeah of
2021 and covered turned up in march
you've probably just waited a bit like
like yeah
i don't think me and you would be
talking about next surge right now if
that was the case so it was probably it
was a massive um you know blessed in
disguise for us that um yeah
to set to set up nexus
so talk to me about so we'll talk about
the last sort of um eight months or so
but like talk to him about the first
year of nexus then like what was was the
sort of mindset like right guys let's
let's just get cracking let's use this
as an opportunity let's start speaking
to our clients get money in the bank
start doing deals what was the mindset
going into that first year then
yeah yeah i suppose it was um very much
you know let's go and
and just attack this right let's go and
really try and set up a business let's
capitalize on the fact that we don't
have this non-compete um what we did was
we were very strategical in our approach
though we didn't go in it like we didn't
just go crazy and just run into our old
markets again you know we sat back and
we said between the four of us what did
we like what did we dislike about chat
black you know what can we recreate you
know what can we actually create
from what we know and i think that's
allowed us to really be able to build up
some values and a vision of what we
wanted to get out of the next you know
the first three four years of nexus
search and we've really been disciplined
around creating
creating that vision which i think
helped us in that first 12 months yeah
where did you get why did you do that i
understand why but like where did that
come from like why did you because you
could have quite easily been like right
[ __ ] out like this has happened now
let's just go get smashing bills and
crack on like why did you why did you
why did you guys stay disciplined on
that and why was that important
because i think we all four of us shared
a very similar value in that we we love
chapman black and it was a great
business to work in but there was
definitely some elements of the company
that you know we were not we were not so
fond of you know we yeah we saw that it
was a company of 100 consultants you
know with
20 25 people making most of the money um
right i know that happens a lot in most
companies and we were just really
passionate about trying to recreate that
you know we didn't want to create a
recruitment company where
you know there's not people generating
revenue there's not people
absolutely
top performers and um that was our focus
going into it was okay then so what do
we need to do now to
to turn nexus search into the most to a
higher performing recruitment company
without you know which is just if it has
to be 20 people
if we just find 20 people and 20 people
are going to take our business to where
it needs to go then we'll just find 20
people let's work on trying to create
them values
yeah no i love that
so
so a few things here then so what would
you say have been like obviously you
started this with three um other guys
yeah we're at chapman black as well talk
to me about firstly what have been some
of the main positives that you've
experienced so far all you guys starting
this journey together because obviously
i'll speak to a lot of people that start
on their own yeah two people like what
would you say have been the main
positives of you guys starting it
together as full of you
um as a business
yeah i think um
probably the the biggest positive is
just like where
we're like we're like a little team you
know we're like a little team we've just
we've got a real
team player mentality between the four
of us um we all bring something
different all different people you know
we're not carbon copies of each other
we're all different people we have
different perceptions on recruitment how
it should be done
and we all just bring something
different to the table and i think
that's really enabled us to constantly
have new ideas and constantly be able to
just choose what is the best idea on the
table and none of us have gone into it
with an ego you know none of us have
gone into it saying oh you know i've
built more than you here or i'm better
than you here we've gone into it as a
complete um you know we are equals we're
running this business together and we
all want to get the best out of it and i
think that's probably been and obviously
you know naturally there's four views
you can split tasks the stuff that's
time consuming between four of you you
can split that up well um yeah and now
that hats off to anyone who's set up a
recruitment company on their own because
you know i don't think you know that is
so difficult with the amount of business
related tasks outside of recruitment
you've got to do and i think with four
of us you just have a luxury a little
bit of being able to spread that
and then what have been some of the
challenges then like has it has it been
difficult for all of you i know you like
you've all been like you said you're a
proper team but what has it been quite
difficult sometimes for all of you to be
aligned with where things are going or
the decision like what have been some of
the challenges
um i think we've never we've never not
been aligned with where the business
needs to go i think that's something
that's probably surprised all of us
actually in that we've all just always
understood where the business needs to
go we've never really had a conflict
there's never been an argument around
what we need to be doing i'd probably
say that the biggest difficulty is that
there is four people in a room and it's
four different personalities i think if
you went into business with one person
you have to understand that one person's
personality you have to yeah you know
manage each other's personalities we've
got four people in the room so it's
managing each each person's personality
you know in a different way and each
person's expectations has to be managed
correctly i think that's probably what
we've had to juggle
that's the hardest thing we've had to
juggle i'd say
so what what's uh what surprised you so
far then obviously you were thinking
about starting a recruitment business in
november but obviously got chucked into
it because of yeah circumstances that
weren't planned but what surprised you
on this journey so far then as phrase
the recruitment business owner now which
is different to being a director in a in
someone else's company
um um what surprised me i think one of
the things that's probably surprised us
the most which is what it shouldn't have
but when we first went into it we we
seek device from a business consultant
so we got a business consulting
um he wasn't to do recruitment but he
trained us at chatham black and we
really liked him we got him in we done a
workshop with him and we went for a
business plan and um
him being someone not from recruitment
you know we was all saying well you know
we're we we're all 400 500 600k billers
you know we're just going to go and do
it again and he was a bit like well
you're not and
he was like he just doesn't work like
that like you run your own business now
like it's not going to happen
and i remember us coming out of that
meeting and we all just kind of looked
at each other and was like
are we not going to do it
are we like
are we not going to do 500k like is that
not going to happen and for about a week
or so we like changed our business plan
and we like low we changed our time why
did you say that though why because like
you you can't just build it's different
you're in a different environment yeah
why did he say he was why did he say
that i think he was just trying to
explain to us that you're like when you
work in a company where there's an
infrastructure you know and all you're
doing is coming into work sitting at a
desk doing recruitment you know you can
do their numbers coming into a business
where you run you run it yourself you
know there's more pressure here or there
you've got more things to do
you know you're not going to go and
replify their numbers um which i think
was a fair statement from him you know
of course he didn't know that he doesn't
know recruitment um so we didn't like we
just took it as
we we might not have believed him but we
did we took it for about a week we might
have believed in and then and then after
that we didn't and i was probably the
biggest surprise for me was that we have
just gone and been able to rectify the
numbers um yeah you know we have all
been able to go and do
um the numbers that we were doing at
chapman black um yeah
you know and more and more to people
would you would you put that what did
you put that down to
like let's just like why a lot obviously
you've got a track record you you like
you've got a there's a collectible view
you probably all kept each other going
holding each other accountable but like
obviously yeah you would have marched 20
to 20 obviously covered all that like
what what what do you think has enabled
you guys to do that because that's
that's still like something super to be
proud of and as you're saying probably
did more than what you're doing at
chapman black so we're like why
yeah and obviously through covered as
well which was a pretty difficult
situation for any recruiter um now to be
honest i think we just um
we took a different approach to an
extent we we saw that kovid was around
we
knew that business development was going
to be different you've got our approach
during covid we could you could just fly
into any decision maker and you know
with a cv and just expect they were
going to interview that tv whether it
matched their market or not you know
which could have been the old way of
doing recruitment it was more about you
know we have to try and find out what
how do we offer a solution as a startup
business
that's flexible that's agile in the
recruitments but in the exec search base
what could we do different to other
companies and we started maybe
offering different proposals we would be
offering much more contingent
recruitment searches that we wouldn't
normally took on we were taking them on
if we saw that it was with a client that
was actively recruiting during that
period um yeah
so we just worked we just worked a bit
more smarter i think in that first year
um
and to be honest
we were just very relentless we we were
very relentless and we all have a high
expectation of each other we have we
pull each other up constantly if we
don't think that each other's at the
right level um you know we've in a whole
two years we've been in extra search not
one of us has ever taken a long lunch
you know if someone turns up one minute
past the hour you know that one of the
other three business partners one of us
is going to look at each other like
you're not allowed to do standing there
but we just hold each other we just hold
each other to a really high discipline
and i think that's what's enabled us
to to do to do them their numbers so far
yeah yeah no fair enough and
what about what how have you gone about
obviously as we said before there's
about what did you say there's like 16
of you now right so how is it how has it
been like hiring for your own business
because that's a whole different thing
in itself like how how's that played out
yeah so in year one off we were we were
we hired really well we hired four
people um which was just what we needed
for our business um for delivery
consultants um
strategy was bring people in with around
one years recruitment experience because
we don't have
you know an infrastructure to train the
absolute basics
so let's bring someone just a bit of
knowledge and we've managed to find four
people that have been you know have been
fantastic for our business they're still
here today you know they've really
created they've created a great layer of
our business um you know they are openly
100 the reason why we was able to to do
even more numbers in year two um we've
done that we we we straight we thought
that hiring was really easy in year one
we come into year two well we coming to
you too like we'll go and hire ten
people this year we've just we found
four people without really trying and
then and then come to year two and we
it's just been it's been so difficult
now i think it's been our hardest thing
um is it because everyone's hiring is it
because
what what's been what have you found
difficult about that
i suppose it is probably we have we
definitely have more competition now you
know people weren't higher in june
covered whereas now people are
i think obviously just the people coming
into recruitment now after covid have a
different perspective on what they see a
recruitment company to look like as well
you know people
people maybe are not i don't think i've
seen as much
i've not seen people super motivated by
what i was talking about the beginning
of this
podcast you know being the top performer
i don't know if that's 100 the driving
motivation behind a lot of people
stepping into recruitment now and it is
it's changed and i think we've as a
business and as business owners we've
had to kind of shift our
our what attracts people to our business
slightly
yeah
and obviously what i thought was quite
good obviously considering where you
guys are on your journey you've also
you've also
you've now got an actual dedicated
internal recruiter as well has that has
that helped
yeah definitely i think that was
something that we
we saw so basically what happened was we
hired them four people and then we we
took our foot off the gas on hiring
because we was like we've got our four
people they're really good going into
year two that's our setup now and we
didn't
we didn't proactively keep approaching
the market um in the first half of this
year and it just left us with a massive
black hole we just didn't have any
candidates yeah you got it i think
that's the thing you've got to be
consistent with it you can't just be
like we need to hire someone now let's
start now yeah that's it and i think um
then we just we said we've got we've got
we hired amber as an ops assistant um
but we were just seeing so much sounds
for there she had so much she's a sales
person you know and we just thought why
don't we just use
this early on that journey let's ingrain
an internal recruit into our business
they understand our culture and we've
just worked so hard over the past four
or five months in in allowing her to
become you know an internal recruiter
and it's now it's now paid off massively
because we've made she's made
three hires in the past three weeks now
uh
yeah good thing about that right is that
obviously you've got someone dedicated
to being consistent getting the nexus
name out there
rather than before i'm assuming maybe
you might do a bit of i don't know you
might do a bit of it someone some of the
guys might do a bit of it in terms of
like the internal firing push yeah well
you just rely on you know you'd speak to
some rector x and you would hope that
they're actually profiles and there's
only so much you can rely on right
direction you know they've got to go
about doing their own recruitment
themselves right
i think having that internal recruiter
that's just consistently pushing next to
search pushing messages out always you
know just trying to find new profiles
for your business i think
for us i think going into next year it's
going to pay it's going to be so
fundamental i think amber's role is
going to really enable us to go and get
you know 20 25 to 2025 heads
yeah i love it so talk to me about as we
finish then talk to me about what what's
on the horizon for you guys then what's
uh obviously getting into this will be
your second year
right pretty much the end of this year
nearly so what what's what's top of mind
what are you guys thinking about
as we get into the end of this year and
go into next year like what's on the
horizon
um so i think for us it's just about it
is about that continued organic growth
with hiring we want to make sure that
we're bringing more people in we plan
for our hiring academy the beginning of
january we want to bring six seven
people into our business which would be
our first talent injection um
we
i'm really i've moved roles now so i've
become more of the sales manager of the
business less around just being a
billion i don't have a billion target on
my head anymore my responsibility is to
to run our company and to try to get the
best out of the new people in the
business so i'm trying to build an
operating model what is the best
practice
i feel like we have a best practice for
a delivery function um now it's about
trying to build a best practice for a
sales function and we've we've got five
sales consultants in the business um
next year's about making them um set
them up to become nexus searches next
top top performers and that's the goal
i love that well phrase has been an
absolute pleasure
thanks for being super honest love your
energy mate love your positive
positivity i think kudos to you guys
like yeah obviously yeah ended up
starting the business journey sooner or
have really later the opportunity you've
yeah that you've got to give them right
so um yeah good good on you guys and
really excited to see where you guys are
over the next couple of years but thanks
for being super honest and sharing
everything that you have in this episode
mate it's been it's been brilliant
i appreciate it thanks for having me on
here